Paul doesn't know that Kimmy and me did it in a blanket fort
on Sundays. She tells him it was C, but it wasn't so. Still,
she's on her knees. >> I love how he can make this video.
He stuff up in this video. And he makes this video without ever
acknowledging the fact that he initially said that this was because
Tinder verifies. >> Yes. Yes. And he lies to Destiny and
says, "Oh, I pointed out my first video that this isn't true."
He is. >> And he sucks at his job. That's the worst part.
That's true. The most offensive part is how terrible
at researching and making videos this guy >> He's in the
fortress. Okay. He's in the bunker. He's having his
downfall right now. Okay. He's having his literal downfall right
now. >> Tie women. How old are you? >> Enough to
get results. >> But you're old enough to not text women
like you're an 18-year-old horny
That's what I'm saying is that maybe you should target other
women.
>> It's a three-way call and he knows
I would actually appreciate your
>> lay a little bit. What? Wait. Playoff
dude. That donation was so on the money. Holy [__]
Oh, [__] >> This guy's got you and Perry calling
him like a child or an abuser.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I have
never said that he is a childer. I just said that if
>> Yeah. You think that's that far off? >> It's pretty
close to being a child. He's He's doing half the work.
No, I'm saying. But do you think do you disagree with that donation?
>> Well, the that Connor would hold down a child for Destiny.
>> Um I don't think Connor would literally hold down a
child for Destiny, but I understand what the donation's saying.
>> Thank you. Oh, what's up? >> I just I think Connor's
getting a lot getting a lot of hate. I think Connor doesn't deserve
that much heat. He's not that bad. He's not like Aerodite.
>> Uh the Hold on. The reason I give Connor heat is because
he talks about standing on like being a principled person, being
a Christian, having like deeply held beliefs and even he totally
folds
>> just like all this he said about oh you guys are normalizing
food shops to me and Charlie like a year or two ago when he was
with PV
and it's like now now all of a sudden no food shop's actually
awesome and uh you know >> what about his doxing take where
he said he would have to immediately distance himself from anybody
who docked because that would just be way over the line. Anybody
who does that is a psychopath. All of these are ideas on the
internet and if you try to take that into real life, you're a
crazy person who I have to distance from. >> Yep. Yep.
>> Sorry. I'm I'm I'm just a little annoyed that this guy
just can't stand behind any of the principles he puts out on
the internet. I thought for sure the lollycon one, like the one
would be the line for him where he's like, "No,
clip of his his wife coming and telling him to stop talking about
kids so much." >> No, but I heard about it.
>> Very funny. You don't actually hear what she says, but
he's like, "You hear her coming, open the door." And he's like,
"My wife's not happy with the the state of the discourse right
now." >> And how how is the uh how's the time off? And
how is your first stream back?
>> Uh good. Good. Play a lot of the bizarre. Play a lot
of the bizarre. >> But that's the answer to both of those
>> Time off. I played a lot of the bizarre stream. Play
a lot of the bizarre. Oh, what did you what did you cover today?
Did you cover any of the initial stuff? All yeah, just all this
just went through all this.
>> Um, people keep telling me that the a bunch of people
in my chat are like, "You got to rebuild the Willie Bridge. You
got to This rebuilds the Willie Bridge, right?" No, >> not
even a little bit. No, >> this guy's like an actual You
don't This guy has been and is a dishonest piece of He was in
a between a rock and a hard place. Had to make take action here.
SN literally some reason unforced error just put Willie in like
the one position where he would actually have to like you know
go completely scorched earth.
And I'm not I will have to look this up after the stream cuz
I didn't get a chance to look it up before. I think there's a
real chance that he was actually legally obligated to do that.
I'm not I'm not joking. I think there's a decent chance he said.
There are places where you have to do that. You're legally obligated.
if you if you are suspicious that there's like um kind of child
sex crime, you are like legally obligated to report it.
So, I don't even know.
I don't know, man. I don't know. We'll see. It's like, does this
undo him like totally like amplifying all of Destiny's lies against
you? No.
>> No, obviously not. >> I I love how he can make
this video, dude. He stuff up in this video. And I mean he makes
this video without ever acknowledging the fact that he initially
said that this was because Tinder
>> Yes. Yes. And he lies to Destiny and says, "Oh, I pointed
out my first video that this isn't true." He lies in those DMs
to Destiny that he uses in his video. Hold on, let me find this.
Destiny says the thing about Twitter age verification and he
literally lies back to him and says, "I looked into this when
I made my vid. I don't think that that is required, but I don't
know. I haven't used Tinder in like 8 years." So now when he
apparently looked into it, >> he said, "Yes, I went and
looked this up as I watched and it's like, no, you literally
said, well, Tinder age verifies. I googled it."
>> Just a lying. He really is. He's so worthless, dude.
He even [__] this up. Like both him and Ether this
up right now with the 60 GB of child,
right? And >> totally irrelevant. Yeah. >> The the
the different DMs uh lumped in with this as well. It's like,
dude, what are you guys even doing? Aren't you guys like crying
that Hassan and Belle smear you guys all the time? Like it's
so annoying that just
they are just like totally worthless opportunist
dishonest just subhuman pieces of [__] It's [__]
so annoying.
>> Oh no, he he went to police. So Willy's cool now. No.
No. Willie is a dishonest sack of [__] and he sucks
at his job. That's the worst part. That's true. The most offensive
part is how terrible at researching and making videos this guy
>> Is that the That's the worst part of
>> Yeah. Okay. >> You just get wrong. I hate just
seeing people repeatedly get wrong. Like fix your [__]
process. >> Dude, I can't believe that um I can't believe
Ethan didn't identify like how big a deal this was.
Like this is the this is the thing, right? This is the whole
thing. Uh, the other thing is is we should get the Willy Mac
before Desty deletes these messages or I hope he exported them
cuz you know what happens when you link stuff from one group
chat to another group chat with a Discord link? It auto embeds
it. >> And if this URL has that same like uh although I
guess Destiny just did you cover his stream. Did you see him
basically admit that Yeah, I did make this group chat. >> Yeah,
he basically confirmed that whole email, right? >> Which
is insane. I don't like what is this guy doing? like >> which
means that that those Twitter DMs seem authentic to me. If if
that email is true, if that that was said in that email is true
and Jesse just come out ado, it seems like this Twitter authentic.
Also, I understand people saying about the header thing. I know
about the header thing. Um but that's mentioned in the email.
I don't understand why you would fake something wrong
but really authentically
>> and then explain it in the email as opposed to just
fake it right. >> Wait, say that again. The header thing.
I'm I'm
>> okay. You understand that the argument is that the header
is wrong. That the header shows destiny. >> Oh, for for
the Sorry, you said the header and the I thought you're talking
about the email still. You're talking about the header for the
um Twitter DMs. >> Yeah, that you could fake it more convincingly.
I I just think you Yeah, you can't know right now, but yeah,
I know what you mean. >> No, but what I'm saying is that
email was the email that was attached to those DMs, right? >> That
email until today, the story in that email was unverified.
>> Yeah. And now the story's corroborated.
So now it seems like there's a higher chance the DMs are authentic.
>> Yeah. Well, I mean, yeah, I that cuz those DMs are like
the I feel like I have to hold myself back from >> Yeah,
I want to I'm not saying they are true or anything, but the thing
it just doesn't make any sense that you would Okay, in this email
that gets everything else right, it then says,
>> oh, the header's like the wrong way around on this.
It's like it says it's Destiny on the header, but I don't know
why that is. I think it might be because Twitter DMs just like
do this after the account's been deleted for long enough. Why
would you say that in the email instead of just faking the correctly?
>> That's true. Yeah, I suppose. Uh I don't know how damning
this will be. I don't use Twitter, therefore I'm unaware of why
her side of the DMs are missing or why his information is at
the top of the DMs as opposed to hers. Best guess is if an account
is deactivated and you revisit your DM thread with them, that's
how it appears. Yeah, I have no I have no idea. But yeah, why
would they do that instead of just faking it accurately? Like
you could literally just go
like this is so
um like to fake if you're like photoshopping if you if you were
mocking up that. >> Well, you wouldn't even have to fake
it or Photoshop it. You just inspect element on some other DMs
and fill them out like you literally
>> um you can you can literally emulate mobile. Uh I think
>> Okay, hold on.
>> Try this. Maybe not. Hold on. Can I get an actual thing
here? Get an actual device here.
Not responsive. Oh, maybe not. Maybe that's not how it works.
I thought I thought mobile device you get the mobile overlay
or something, but apparently not.
Never mind. >> Uh, no, you kind of do, don't you? Isn't
that you've got the >> I didn't have the bottom I didn't
have the bottom four pieces or whatever. >> Oh, sure. Right.
Yeah. Yeah. >> Might be harder. You could probably still
do it in some way, but yeah, maybe HTML or sorry, maybe um Photoshop
would be the way. Still wouldn't be difficult. I mean, they might
they might not be, you know, obviously still not confirmed. Absolutely
not confirmed. Not confirmed in any way, but it just doesn't
it it seems pretty plausible to me.
>> Go to Tom's. Dude, I've also been getting clips from
Tom's stream. Tom stream's been uh he's been on one >> Yeah.
Yeah. I I saw him saying like you have to preserve it and like
there might be truth to the idea that you have to preserve it
and if he wasn't aware it was like cam, but the thing is that
CE is like strict liability. So once you're aware, I think you
have to over the place. Once you've got a suspicion, I think
you've got to like
>> I don't see how there could be anything else where like
cuz it's clear what he's doing, right? I don't know. I didn't
get a chance to see any of your coverage, but to me it's clear
what he's doing. He's hoping it blows over in the in the case
where it doesn't. He doesn't want to get caught having deleted
evidence,
>> But he's just hoping it will blow over. Like with CSAM,
you can't hope it blows over and then when you do get caught
or you do get like you can't go, "Oh, I was just hoping I could
save this for like a possible investigation." It's like brother.
No. No. That's crazy. Hold on. I'm going to try to find this
tom clip. Just the particular one is uh quite good. Give me a
second. Oh, maybe this isn't it. >> That's probably not
true. His lawyering these records who all need to be able to
>> Oh, this is a different one. There's a different There
was a there's another clip here where he just talked about how
like um when he was in middle school, people all the time in
the '90s, people used to kids all the time.
This one is basically him arguing that like, don't you guys understand
that like the lawyers and like Pixie and so many other people
would have the same CP? Like it's actually not that bad to >> That's
probably not true. His lawyers probably have copies of these
things. His lawyers probably have copies of it. It's already
been submitted to the courts. So now the courts have uh copies
of it. The defense team or sorry the prosecutor team, the
sorry the plaintiff's team also has copies of these things. So
literally like like truly Pixie probably has copies of all of
this stuff now on her own computer. She probably has copies of
everything that Destiny's team has sent over. He they Pixie may
have even have copies of CP on her computer now as well. Like
there's probably tons of there. You can't you literally can't
make up how
I I don't know if anyone on Naggi said this, but just watching
some of these like the low tier orbiters try to make arguments
without Destiny's talking points, like the the things they're
coming up with to try to defend this is
is wild. >> The people who are holding these records, who
all need to be able to look through them for their own court
cases, they all probably currently have CP now. All of them.
Like there's probably tons of lawyers, tons of people involved
in these cases who all currently are likely holding CP. >> All
right,
better one. Better one. This one is a good one. Guys, listen.
There's like lawyers who probably have this evidence that Guys,
guys, it's so bad. Has a
lawyers, judges, maybe even cops, all have this same evidence.
All have CP transcripts still not been unsealed.
Uh, nope.
>> Like I I've also talked about the fact that when I was
younger, so like all of this like obsession with
today,
for those of you who are younger, you don't know this, but the
the obsession with today is very new. This is very, very new.
And I don't mean new as in like
back in the,
you know, 15th century kings were marrying 12y olds. Like, no.
I mean, like, in the '9s,
it was like very normal for adults to be with underage people.
There was uh it was very normal to them. It was very normal to
to to like underage kids. It was very normal for for like when
I was in middle school. >> Hold on. When he was in middle
school, I want to see where that goes. Hold on. When Tom was
in school, >> is very new. was uh it was very normal to
them. It was very normal to >> when he was in middle school
>> to like underage kids. It was very normal for for like
when I was in middle school and high school. I remember girls
saying they were dating guys in college. I remember these things.
>> That's what happened. >> Okay. Is that Wait, is
that what happened here?
>> It's just like that's not what's happening at all. mad
as well, but it's like it's a different it's a different SC.
It's we're like talking about a different, you know, we're doing
a different thing here. >> Yeah. Yeah. We're talking about
a very different thing. Yeah. Like a 17-year-old dating like
a 20-year-old guy is could be weird possibly. But then maybe
it's not weird. Maybe he was 18, she was 15, they met
high school or some he's talking about like younger than 17.
I feel like it's not like, you know, 15 >> middle schoolers
dating college kids. That's also a little weird. >> That's
also a little weird. It's like it's it's uh not on the same scale
as like a guy in his 30s going for like 17 year olds and not
giving a [__] about ages when he's talking to just
like random people on Twitter. >> It also it looks bad
when he's got a bunch of clips on the internet talking about
how like he has no interest in immature girls and and then he's
like confessing. He's like sending all his Lauren Southern DMs.
>> Well, I I even remember the one that I saw tonight.
I didn't remember him trying to say to Dan that the age of consent
should be lowered to 16
>> or whatever the [__] it was he said. >> Is
that is that from anything else?
>> No. No, it's from when he was in LA. He's like 16 17
be legal. Like, dude, what? Okay, man. >> Uh, over right
now. >> Where is that? Yeah. I don't where I got >> What
do you uh What are your thoughts on the people who say stuff
like, "Thank God Will Thank God at least Willie Mack went to
the cops. I'm tired of people not taking this seriously.
>> It's like
Yeah. Um, obviously aware of people going to the police. So listen,
that's been Willy's the last guy to do that. Okay. >> Okay.
Hold on.
This Listen, I know I was a fan of this guy. I think we were
all fans of this guy. Okay, shut the [__] up, Kilo.
I bet you you liked this guy before Max came around. I bet you
you thought this guy was cool for a short period of time.
We all have our problems. All right, >> Max really was
the great filter. You know, if you weren't gone around that time,
then >> uh I didn't hate Max, though. Okay,
>> that was like the first time I was ever on stream. >> Yeah,
I don't see this clip. I don't know where I got sent this, but
I was on stream earlier and this guy just says Wait, uh, wait,
maybe I have it. Oh, I don't I can't.
>> Okay. Was it from Augie stream? Someone's got it. >> I
guess I got sent it at some point. I don't know where it is,
though. >> Give me a time stamp from your stream. I hate
Max because he speaks too slow.
Well, hold on a second. It's from the Hassan video. What?
>> Destiny defend. Oh yeah. >> Lowering the age of
consent before. >> I feel like I could give so many hot
takes, but I can never say them because >> Here's a hot
take, but I I would defend it. That's the I'm not just saying
hot takes my Here's one. I defend it. Ready?
>> 16 and 17 year old people should be legal. Should be
legal. >> I got to go. I'll be back in a little >> If
you're going to hold people that are 16 years old, >> is
that is that poetic? Isn't that poetic? 16 17 should be legal.
I got to go.
That just >> I mean Yeah. He's also got all of those clips
about the Dr. Disrespect thing, right? Where he's like, "Yeah,
it seemed pretty clear that he was on Dr. Disrespect's side in
terms of [__] a 17-year-old the whole time, right?"
Like, he's just like, "I don't I'm not mad about this. I don't
care about this. I don't care about this." No. No. This No. Dan
did in fact go forever accountable for the dumb that they tweet.
Then you know what? They should have all the other rights and
every responsibilities that come along with being a adult. Talk
about how actually it's not.
>> Oh, what do you think of Dan defecting to Ethan and
giving him all the dirt on Destiny? You know, he's spilling all
of it to Ethan so Ethan can kill this guy, >> dude?
I don't know if he is. I feel like I feel like Dan's
I like Dan will just play the middle ground. D survive right
now. Okay, this is bad.
>> That's pretty bad. Yeah, dude. This guy uh
dude
I just keep getting linked to his logs uh from TG chat. He's
in the fortress. Okay. He's in the bunker. He's having his
downfall right now. Okay. He's having his literal downfall right
>> Hold on. Where are these things?
He was um
he was linking
seeing that the top comment on the H3 video was his and posting
it in in either my Discord or Kelly's. I can't even tell. But
he like he posts this with the thing. our way of
>> He started 2025 and he was like, I'm going after Hassan.
Hassan's my number one up and now we're >> twothirds of
the way.
wants to take out
>> this Destiny's enemy now. Okay. God,
what else has he got going on here? The dumbest part is when
people like Hassan hijack that narrative and pretend it's happening
to them.
What's this? I don't even know. Yeah, I see. Like you continue
to say like this, ignoring the fact that literally all of this
is just drug out of 2022, 2023.
Hold on. What? What is he losing it on ready said Zurg for? It's
all about isolating you. Destiny. It's actually unhinged malicious
campaign against you cuz you're a
honestly. You make it easy for them cuz you give no about
ban incoming Omega Lol. Yeah, I see like you continue to say
like this and ignoring the fact that literally all of this is
just drug out of 2022, 2023.
See, you're not even wrong, but society runs on optics. 2024,
2025 has literally been the most boring year in so far as drama
goes. It's literally just this thing getting sucked back from
the past.
No, actually, in the year of our Lord, 2020, wait, hold on. It
was technically in 2024, okay, that he started a group chat where
he started sharing images of this minor to people including purportedly
according to the email actual uncensored cam
did a group chat. Okay. I'd say that's pretty big drama that's
happened in the past year. Would you say queen? I feel like that
would be big drama for most creators.
Yep. I think he's actually benefited not getting covered as much.
If anyone else behaved the way Dashi behaved, he would have been
covered far more for far
>> I think I think also his uh like his total spur out,
his total like
like just starting to dox whoever he can attack call for death
like I think that prevented a lot of criticism too. Like I think
a lot of people are just like well like I think he was destroying
his reputation but it's been kind of silent in the background
as well that like people are like okay we'll wait for him to
punch himself out and then we'll cover it. I don't know. That's
my in my mind I feel like that's what people were doing. Maybe
not. Maybe they would have just let him come back. But you see
the very violent logs. Anybody link those to >> I did.
I saw them in Discord or some at some point. Yeah.
>> Just the Destiny Willy's destroying your reputation.
You have to debate him. >> Totally spazzing out.
That person is a strange strange person. I got to say that or
you tweet about him is very funny. I always see that circulating
or post her face. This is face of the DJ. Uh, how was did you
watch a lot of Augie stream?
Did uh >> Oh, yeah. I watched my straight. Yeah. >> Was
it good? >> It was all right.
>> I watched up until he went to the what was it like Tonka
saw it like that
that combo or are you talking about tonight or the one before
that? >> Oh, I watched both I watched both. But >> Okay.
Okay. I don't know what you covered tonight. I don't know if
you covered anything new.
>> I watched uh I did watch all your streams tonight on
kick. >> See here. People are legitimately. They don't
think I'm not taking every single precaution necessary under
advice of C counsel. That's all I'll say. Lol W. I'm sorry.
I feel like somebody's got to email Andrew Breler and say, "Hey,
did your client inform you that he may have been in possession
of CSAM in December of this year?" And then you advised him to
delete it, not notify the cops, and keep it to himself. Oh, sorry,
to delete it from the >> to like download it to a different
hard >> Okay. him saying like
that I've got nothing handed over to the police yesterday.
>> Yeah, I know. Uh oh, you caught that Hassan covered
that thread, too. Yes.
So good. I love this Hassan guy. You wouldn't even believe how
much I love this Assassan guy. >> Asan has come in clutch.
I can't lie. Han's pretty awesome, >> dude. The white hat
joke was also just such a banger. Okay, I don't know if he came
up with that or not, but white hat was so funny to me. Like Destiny's
just retaining CS Sam on the off chance that he can help some
investigator in the future. He's just trying to identify the
victim so he can reach out to them personally and make sure they're
doing
>> I thought it was crazy Ethan just like saying, "Yeah,
this guy's keeping his jerk off, too. Everyone knows it." It's
just like >> I I don't know if he's wrong. I thought that
was unhinch, but I thought it was funny as >> Yeah, it
was funny. I laughed,
>> dude. of this.
>> I do actually like you know Destiny's comment on Ethan's
video is cringe as [__] He's crashing out. But I
actually do give him kind of the point on that halfway cuz Ethan
is a total [__] Uh he is [__] the story.
He is getting wrong.
Um he has done this before. He does just run like this with very
little vetting.
Um it is performative. He is just trying to make sure he can't
be associated or be sweeping in any way. But Destiny's been more
than happy to weaponize him knowing that. And Destiny has bit
his tongue on things he otherwise would have criticized
>> Dude, dude, the whole line about reading my revenge
when like Ethan's been totally happy to reference the that Destiny
leaked about denims, right, over and over again. I can't remember
if Ethan actually read them, but was Destiny losing his mind
about that when Ethan was using um the leaks from Destiny about
denims against him? No. No, it's only when there's about Destiny
that the revenge were like a problem. I guess it's it's wild
that uh he can it's wild that he can apply these double standards
like so easily and with like no introspection
like oh actually when you leak about me that's revenge that's
like you're reading my revenge when you read those but like for
everybody else no it's like I'll do that whenever I want. >> Yeah.
It's like even if I'm like annoyed at some joke someone makes
something the idea I would complain about is like completely
unthinkable to me. So I I literally don't know how this guy like
lives with himself just blatantly
like doing [__] that he condemns. I I tr I actually
don't know. >> Yeah,
very hopefully not for much longer. Okay, we're manifesting.
Okay, we're manifesting. You saw the meme, right? The DGL.
Do I have to show you guys his chats from this? I'll I'll back
off. I'll back off. >> Go watch the Willy Mack video. Go
watch the Willy Mac video. That's simple,
right? Not the the most recent one, but
>> was it the second one? >> Which one you talking
about? >> One where this guy says, "I'm going to I'm going
to kill these people. I want
>> I want to go on assassination mission and kill these
people." >> I know. I know. I know. I know. Yes. Yeah.
I mean, wait, you saw these logs, too, right? The logs from today.
>> Winks and nods at people. Oh, you definitely saw them,
but I'll pull them up anyway. Oh, well, the one where he's like,
uh, people in storage,
whatever the [__] >> Yep. Feel like Jay-Z and
Queen will never stop and they have no content of their own,
so they can dedicate 24/7 to this. Not sure how how one would
stop that. It just come down to other communities, especially
this one. Not being about everything.
Uh-huh. Desessie, when you say not being about, what do you mean
exactly? Genuinely curious. You know what I mean,
>> My heart of hearts I do. We'll literally cover this
loser at this >> Doesn't matter is the answer to that.
74212.
What is this?
This is what's next.
Benjamin Netanyahu, very good guy. Also another war criminal
genocide there
"I love the Palestinians." That's what he said. He said, "I'm
the biggest fan of Palestinians. You can't say Oh, I came in
way too early for this, but hold >> About to hit the time
stamp I got given. Destiny, he's a streamer, not a big fan of
mine. Not a good guy.
Said, "I've never done anything inappropriate with minors." He
would
He would know. This guy, he lives in Florida. Can you believe
it? He's got a very patriotic son. I wish him well.
>> He's just making new voters for me every day. Every
day of the week. Can you believe it? Can you believe it?
>> I'm Dude, I actually said today during the stream like,
"Okay, Hassan, you got to stop doing drama. You're going to take
my audience. [__] you. [__] you,
>> But I'm in support of keeping it."
>> He's funny when he [__] I don't know why
he doesn't go into the mod more. It's cuz this gay [__]
audience are like, "Uh, this isn't about the Garson's being genocided
right now, so you need to stop talking about that." It's because
of that [__] bro. He's so funny when he's just talking
[__] on people. >> Uh, hold on. We got another
Tom Flurry clip. I don't want to see it. >> I don't even
I don't even know. Tom, would you be willing to say some 17-year-olds
are likely to be attractive to you at your age? Now,
>> you can be doing it without it. So >> why would
you >> Tom? Would you be willing to say some 17-year-olds
are likely to be attractive to you at your age now?
>> Yes, I am willing to say there are time at my age. >> 10
toes down.
10 toes down, boys. >> Seen 17year-olds and thought, >> yeah,
they're kind of attractive. Sure.
>> I mean, he is the primary vector.
>> That's rough, man. It's rough. >> Men are not
programmed to be unattractive to people based on a age like that.
>> Tom is
actually just spitting hot Mr. Girl fire right now. >> What
I need what I need Tom to do is I need to pull up pictures of
like a banana at various stage and label them with age ranges.
>> That is not we are our biology does not say well you
need to make sure the age before you know whether or not the
person is attracted. It's postpubescent, right? Whether or not
they are past puberty, if they have gone through puberty, you
are attracted to postpubescent features. If we're talking about
a 17-year-old, and let's 17-year-old hasn't gone through [__]
puberty, that like you're you think it's >> this guy's
kind of crazy. >> I I have no reason to believe that it
would be weird for somebody to find her unattractive,
but you finding >> it's just crazy how the cycle happens
where like, you know, cuz Destiny fought with Mr. Girl, talking
points like this was just like, you're a weirdo. You're a if
you say like this, right? And now Desi benefits from these talking
points and they all come back out and we have to pretend that
like we didn't see like how this cycle all happened. It was like
it was weird and then Mr. Girl came into fashion. Everybody's
like, "Oh yeah, these are like kind of interesting topics." And
then Mr. Girl accused Essie of abusing women. And then it was
like no this makes you and now like basically Desie's been accused
of being attracted to young women like 17-year-olds a gay and
now it's like oh actually we're back to just you know it's all
postpbs and features. That's all it is. Guys, have you ever seen
the shade test? women standing behind a shade and you just based
on their silhouette men find like 16 year olds the most attractive.
Have you not seen this study?
I can't remember if Max referred to that study or not. I've seen
it referred to.
>> This guy's just pulling up the the elite law. This stuff
Mr. G doesn't even talk about. That's crazy. This guy's like
>> stuff hidden knowledge of >> I think I think that's
the Max I think Max was the person who told me about that. Used
to watch some Max streams from time to time. All right. Oh, what
was I looking for? I was looking for something before this. Oh,
we did the Yeah, the more winking. >> The only thing I
saw him doing is saying that uh it's the exact same thing as
Chard when Chard didn't exchange any
>> Did you see Wait, did you see people telling him to
like go to that
>> I've seen >> I didn't see people saying it. I
saw him say it, but I didn't see other people saying it. >> I
didn't see him say it. Yeah, I didn't see him say it. Did you
show him the West by the way? Anything else? No, but that's funny.
I might >> Oh, when he says about teeny boppers or whatever
the [__]
>> it's like a whole section. He's like, "Yeah, call college
girls who don't know anything." My favorite. I don't know if
that's exactly what he says, but it's like it's
>> uh it's like nerdy. I think it's nerdy is the word I
search for here. Wes is basically saying like, "How about you
stop texting like a 14-year-old or an 18-year-old virgin and
you won't start you won't keep attracting like the same kind
of the same kind of clientele?" >> Stop. You're I know
what you're saying. You're saying this whole take about how I
don't want a girl who wants for my wealth. Look like what I already
have. Look at my
roll. We roll. in the sense of like I've never seen a man's DMs
that have made me more uncomfortable in my life than when >> Jesus
Christ.
Okay, listen. They like the cat faces. >> All right. Let's
go to the next thing >> Best thing is like Wes tries to
move on or sorry, Desi tries to move on. Wes not going to like
it. >> You are a master at this, my friend. >> Yeah,
you're a master.
>> Do you want to learn about Tyler the Creator's new album?
>> Why the would we want to talk about? They thought you
were a big Tyler the creator. We talk about that for real >> Tyler
the creator. >> No, I don't know. >> Let's go back
to it.
>> If you have videos of you seducing uh >> How old
are you? Taiish girls. >> I can I can tell you. Thai women.
How old are you? >> Enough to get results. >> But
you're old enough to not text women like you're an 18-year-old
horny
>> That's what I'm saying is that maybe you should target
other women cuz the type of women you're targeting where that
works on is >> people that watch streamers.
Stop [__] these type of women. [__] >> Yeah.
Should I walk into the professional world and be like, "Hey,
I'm looking for a >> walk into the world, be like, "Hey,
look at this Rolex." >> Yeah. Dress like a 30-year-old
>> Put on some nice clothes and try to attract a 30-year-old
woman. Yes. Like, yes. Yes. All of those things would be >> Look
at this $10,000 whatever you have. Look at my $100,000. >> That's
so cringe. Why? >> It is cring. I'd rather the people that
like the cat faces than the people that want the $200,000 watches.
Why would I want some money hunter girl? >> Look like a
17-year-old [__] a
>> Yeah. As opposed to like here. >> Is he pretending
to be the 16-year-old or the 17-year-old in that instance?
>> My $300,000 car with my $100,000 watch like of course
it's cringe. But you know >> At least the girls that like
the cat faces don't have like fake lips and fake tips and fake
boobs and fake asses
and fake in your case. 90% of the world is doing the way that
you call cringe and you're the >> I don't know if 90% of
the world is doing the way that you are. I'm pretty sure this
is Miami Beach and [__]
are buying Rolexes to pick up checks on >> It's the guy's
way to do. >> Yeah. You're like, "Hey, check out my Rolex."
Look at picture two. That's real expensive. I got those NFT certificates
to back it up. >> The more wealth you use in the pursuit
of And that is the natural. >> I don't want people that
are my wealth. >> Okay, but none of them are getting your
wealth. You're destroying >> No. The type of people name
a single woman that's gotten your wealth. The type of people
last anything with her. >> The type of people that are
>> Shut the up. You're I know what you're saying. You're
saying this whole take about how I don't want a girl who wants
for my wealth. But no, >> no, no, no. That's not even what
I'm saying. You're literally just saying. No, that was not what
I'm saying. >> Okay, go ahead. >> The type of women
that are attracted to wealth are not the type of No, they're
I don't want to say it's just not my type of person. >> Why?
Because I like the like the nerdy college like attitude vibe
like anime people. That's just like my world that make them young
and younger. >> I don't know how you want me to dude.
the anime vibe just like the attitude. They got an attitude and
they're like nerdy and like >> just like comes off like
soorded, man. It just comes off disordered like straight up.
It's like >> describe it like the people that are the legal
lawyer people or whatever. I don't know what the
>> Well, it's getting >> all those lawyer anime fans.
Okay. He wants female legal mindset. Okay. >> I feel like
the show's over, right? >> Whatever the the online that
era of whatever people.
>> The Have you the people around here with like the crazy
lips and the It's gross. >> Yeah. This is gross. I agree.
>> I don't like it. But those are the types of people that
want to see you step out of a expensive car with a Rolex. >> That's
fair. That's fair. But it's not like you have to specialize in
these type of women. You could plop from anywhere. But why would
I? I just don't want to roll my Instagram. See what happens.
Okay, I'll get it. >> Post some Richard Mill on your Instagram.
See what happens. >> What do you think? What happens?
>> I think you get you get scouted by a different different
breed of woman. >> What type of woman? >> The type
of women that aren't uh cosplaying as 14-year-olds putting on
braces. Uh the >> gross. No. What? You're talking about
the Bella Delpine hunters. >> The fact that they aren't
needing
>> Okay. What do we um
>> asking me? You got it. God, dude. Wes Wes just killed
them. Okay,
a great episode. Great episode.
You love to see it. Oh, there are men who are hotter and richer
and more charismatic and kinder and smarter and more and cooler
and funnier and more interesting and in more interesting parts
of the entertainment industry. Wow. Thank you, Babka. That's
true. What else has been going on? Didn't Destiny listen to West?
He did. H
trying to think of anything else here that I was curious about.
Dude, I I'm actually uh I find I'm like the least
I I don't think this really moves the needle in terms of like
I I think he's down to like basically like a core audience right
now. Like I don't think I don't think we see him drop below like
5,000 viewers or something consistently.
I don't I think those people have already all been weed like
weeded out. >> Fresh updates. I'm seeing Destiny saying
the hardest part is maybe admitting Vosch was right. Lol W just
need the fortress arc. >> That's not even new, is it? That's
not even new. It's a while back. But yeah, need the fortress
arc. >> Wash did intellectually outpace Destiny. We've
been saying this. He did when he said that [__] >> Also,
he had Destiny's number when he said Destiny positions are spy
based. Yeah. Totally accurate analysis and he totally read them.
>> It took years to realize for many
I've been saying that for a while. That is Destiny's not wrong.
Okay. The toughest pill to swallow is the one where Vos was actually
correct all the things he said. Yep.
I hate it cuz maybe it won't be true, but Vos Bosch was telling
you like 3 years ago, Republicans are total fascists and talking
to them at all this insane and you just need to like stamp these
people stomp these people into the dirt and it turns like I don't
know unfortunately that seems to have just been correct and
me also arm yourself if you see a truck going through your neighbor
>> fire from your windows. Okay. Not everything. Not everything.
>> We're just not there yet. Okay. We just haven't realized.
Okay. H
man.
Well, look, you mentioned your DMs. Yeah. I don't think I've
ever represented these DMs in a different way. I try to be really
careful cuz I I obviously don't want to get him to like I wouldn't
want somebody to like or I guess him to leak the other side of
these and make me look like a liar. So, I always say like, "No,
I was pretty convinced this person was not a minor. I was pretty
convinced that uh like I basically messaged the solo guy and
been like, "Hey, just so you know, like you didn't do a good
job of censoring these. Look, this is her like Twitter handle
I think you I think you really this up and you should actually
make sure her obssec is tight cuz I think she's about to get
found by a ton of people who are wild or gay and >> and
you're actually uh kind of slightly slightly wrong there because
she didn't get found off of that. She got found cuz this went
into his chat and was like, "Hey guys." >> Well, they found
the the Twitter profile. I just assumed off of the Twitter profile
they could find her. >> They did find the Twitter profile
pretty
Yeah. So anyway, I I thought that was why he said she was a a
minor. >> Luckily, I never had any uh like CSAM or what
I suspected to be CSAM. So,
>> close. Uh yeah,
I think whoever whoever found that stuff
decided to crop things. Has Destiny ever explained why he posted
her picture like that? Yeah, today he did it. He basically was
like, "Yeah, I just want Kiwi Farms to find her for me, which
is [__] insane.
That's like a insane thing to say. >> One odd thing to
say or an odd thing to do or just an odd
set of decisions, >> dude. People
are like going in on Really for that conversation. And I understand
there were parts of that conversation that were weird, but Destiny
is doing things like funny. The twin stuff is just so funny.
>> I think I think he tried to like he walked that back
pretty fast and was like, "That's like a meme thing."
>> No, it was just so funny. It's like he's like, "Oh,
I could do this for my twin. What would that change, dude? What
would that change? >> Identical twin." >> Yeah. But
like I kind of get the thing where it's like, dude, he's making
such bad decisions that it's like, dude, is there is this really
like could he be this lost in the sauce that he's making decisions
this bad? Is that possible? >> Oh man,
just so I'm sorry. I'm just on the twin. That is just so funny.
I was I was watching that last night or whatever it was just
losing my mind. I was laughing so hard
just like dude, what are you saying right now?
This mean Nicholas blocked Cherry, I guess. Oh, never mind. Maybe
I just been blocked. It's probably just me that's blocked. Still
blocked. How unfortunate, guys. Where does Reley stand on it?
I think I I heard Really was streaming about it tonight and was
just like, "Oh, never mind. Never mind. This guy's out of his
mind." >> I was actually see Wait, pull up Riley's reaction.
I want to see what Riley says. I want to see him realize how
like how insane this is in real time. I have to >> Uh if
anyone's got clips, I don't know how far he would have gone into
it. I'm probably not I'm not pulling up his full reaction tonight.
I'll maybe scout it in a little bit and see what happens.
But yeah, I'm not I'm not gonna pull it up >> There must
be just like a clip of the moment he
destiny admit that he posted for Keith.
>> Oh, I would I would go to that moment if somebody can
find me the time stamp for that when when he goes to find where
um where Destiny says basically. Yeah. Like I I post Yeah. Somebody
asked like did you really post that like just to get Kiwi Farms
to die? He's like, "Yeah, I I wanted to find her." And brother,
what >> really was hating on his today? Well,
that could be easier sometimes,
>> dude. Some people are just like so
Yeah, but his dude, shut up for two seconds. Okay. With the But
>> I watch a little bit of the loner box stuff and I did
see some
I don't know interesting points.
I get it a little bit. I get why these people hate Hassan. I'm
just I it was way easier for me to just be like I'm going to
reset and relearn why I hate him. If if he's going to prove to
me that I should hate him again, then he he'll do it pretty quickly.
And frankly, the White Hat thing, it's going to take a lot of
anti-semitism for him to turn me >> No, the one that's
got me right, there's two that have got me like, you know, I'm
like gooststepping Kyling for his song right now,
>> No, no, no. That one's not even that to be honest. That
one's okay. It's not even that good.
>> It's the uh the one that Rum was sorting out about where
he's like, >> "Whoopy,
I can't wear my bikini to the beach. I can't eat koo day and
my bikini to the beach. Whoopy.
>> That's why we need to keep them."
That one got me. That's got me as a song fan. And the other one
is the Knox one where he's like playing the Twitch's hand song.
He's like, "I am an Israeli music artist." And this is my art.
>> Don't you just like his racist Israeli voice? That's
>> the rac Israeli racism is awesome.
>> Uh you caught he did that in the uh the Ela thing, right?
The wider version of the Ela Klein uh raid bit.
Did you watch Did you go back and watch that? >> I didn't
watch that. No. >> Oh, I went back and watched that whole
thing. Dude, when you watch like the the previous like 10 or
15 minutes for context, it's so bad. like the IDF rolling through
Habbron and like uh taking some late some old Maldi's got like
some boxes she's taking home. They like knock them. She like
she like drops one and they come over and they start stomping
on her boxes. >> From what I'm saying is just totally I
mean I can imagine vibe >> and Han's watching it. Han's
saying, "Yeah, if all these people like turned on these guys
who are doing this, like that would be legal and moral." That's
like how he starts that whole rant is he's talking about like
clear abuses of power by the IDF and Habbron,
right? So like it's all within the same context of like within
Habbron within like area A. It's insane that like this is happening.
And somehow people are like, "No, he's clearly putting a target
on Helocin's back." Kind of wild. Okay, what else we got? Got
other funny stuff tonight, guys. Let me check. Let me check.
Not this. I'm going to need I'm going to need a third person
to join this VC and bring the energy up. Okay.
Where they
Where's somebody at? Where's Auggie? Where's Auggie tonight?
Is he gonna come on here? Is he going to celebrate? >> Ask
Kenny to come cry if actually this is this thing's winning or
some >> he's clicked the Tom link. Which Tom link? Oh,
did you Hold on. Did you see Benny come on the other night
appearance? That was uh he went pretty
>> Always goes on. >> Jesus. Augie's online. I messaged
Augie. We'll see what he's doing. >> Benny always
joins when he's got some [__] to say. Okay, that's
that's a guy who only joins when he got some [__]
to >> This cute animal video before you go. How many naps
does a mini Daxon take in a day? H I'll let this play in the
>> Good morning, buddy. >> Dude, I need I need Connor
to send me this VOD. Okay, I need Connor's VOD from not yesterday,
not today. >> For it. I've been pestering him for it as
well.
>> I want the one before that. I think he said some insane
that he knows he can't stand on anymore. I think he's going to
let that [__] go. >> He said he told me he
appealed it. He told me he appealed the copyright. >> He
told me he appealed it, too. But that's a dude. Can you only
appeal it? You can't download the VOD anymore when it's copyright
struck.
>> Well, yeah. I mean, you can hassle him to Wait, has
him download the VOD for >> Yeah, that's what I want.
Want to watch that VOD? I was very good to watch it. >> Dude,
did you watch did you watch the Perry stream? You watched the
Powder Cake segment? >> Yeah, I probably watched it. I
watched most of Perry's
stuff is related to honor or something. >> It's uh kind
of It's pretty nuts. Okay. It's pretty nuts and pretty funny.
>> Yeah, I told him. I told him it's it's it's too much.
He's using slander as a crutch for comedy. He's just like, you
know, going going insane. It's a bit >> Is it slander?
Conor's like somewhat of a public figure. I think Perry really
believes it. >> I don't think Perry believes it. I think
Perry's trolling.
>> Yeah, I think he does have to figure out. The one thing
he has to figure out is if he wants to seriously like debate
people and stuff because I think he's like obviously not dumb.
But I think for me, not the Connor stuff, when he went on food
chops stream, it's like you can you could probably just win those
debates if you wanted, but then he starts like leaning into bits
and trolling as well, which is funny. I guess food chops isn't
serious, but I don't know. It's really I don't know how to walk
that line, I guess, between like just openly trolling and trying
to be serious. Perry got destroyed by Aiden at bait. I don't
really believe that. Where's morale? Aiden Perry Dickers. I don't
know, but I'm uh
>> Harry and Aiden are hanging out in Mort right now. Okay.
>> Are they?
>> Augie's out tonight, so yeah, I'm going to Nander.
Good. Kickle ban with a file police report. I don't know if that's
true. I don't think that's true.
Oh, I did get blocked by Dorio. I thought so cuz when I looked
at your quote tweet, I was pretty sure it actually showed that
you
like when this shows if I hard refresh this, it'll show as like
uh
Hold on. Let me just make sure this doesn't Yeah. Yeah. So when
I hard refresh and it shows post is unavailable. That's cuz you
got blocked. You got blocked. Raid M when you call it a night.
Do I really want to do that? Do I really want to reward the behavior
we were watching?
I don't feel like I do with other people online. LTG's online.
Malak's online. I thought Connor's development chart was pretty
cool. What do you think of that? >> I The only thing I
had to say there I think I still have it up. The only thing I
wanted to say here was I was just like like why was he not the
Was he not the kind of guy? Maybe I'm just totally misrepresenting
him, but like when Max was discussing stuff, would he have just
been like this is all normalizing?
Like when you're discussing the difference between and a femophilia
like that that feels like that would have been who he was, but
I don't I don't know if I watched enough of his content to know
for sure. I don't remember. I don't really remember.
>> End on the tom link. What's the Tom link? Relink it.
I already watched this tom clip. You just missed it. The Tom
17-year-old clip. Devil RZ. You keep ask me to watch a tom link.
You You asked me like three times now. It's just this one. We
watched it already. We watched >> Going to say some 17.
>> Yeah, we watched this. You just missed it. Was the Warhammer
take on Pedos? I have no idea. It's a new one I asked like a
100 times. I have not gotten it. Throw in the Discord. It got
swallowed by kick. I've not seen the link. throw in the Discord.
Discord.gg/jok
and uh the stream content or content suggestions. Either one.
I can find it in either one. You actually got to link it properly,
bro. Oh, you saw the updates from Dan, right? The Twitter updates
as well, like canceling >> what updates canceling the memberships
>> That doesn't sound
conversation with Ethan and being like,
it's too far.
No, I can't see your link. So, join the Discord. Post in the
Discord.
>> This guy's like guys like this are like annoying as
I've got just >> I know. I kind of want to see whatever
the same thing Tom said though. So, unfort Unfortunately, he's
got me here a little bit. I actually do want to see the Tom link
the Tom clip. So, I wonder what Destiny would do if he was forced
to quit streaming just mauled and DG all day. I have no idea.
He'd probably just watch streams. Seems to be quite happy to
just sit there and watch streams. All I know for sure, Ozel,
is that no matter how much free time he has in a day, he will
not spend any significant portion of it hanging out with Aerodite.
Okay, that's all I know for sure. It's titled R/ Destiny. >> You
think you can take me on alone?
>> He is not alone.
>> Don't call it a comeback.
Somebody somebody actually made this.
>> Wow, that's so cool. These guys are so Wow, a 28-year-old
compsai major made
Now I've spit on my screen. Are you happy? Are you happy with
yourself? Forcing streams better. Are you happy now? I've spit
on my screen. That's [__] up. Uh,
did you see Destiny saying Dan will be a JCO adjacent antifan
in the next six months? I believe that was Pisco he was talking
about. I believe that was Pisco.
Not 100% sure.
Unless I'm mistaken. I believe that was
>> Okay. Dan's a queen of Jason. >> Yep. I'm sure
he is. Okay. This is my last chance. I'm I'm checking the Discord,
guys. not posted his clip in the Discord. So, now we're ending
on a different clip. Okay, now we're ending on an Nerdite clip.
That's your fault, Devil Riz.
All your fault. I'm I've done two years of psychology. I can
mind reading people. I know what's going on. I bet you everyone
has autism because I'm going to diagnose everyone because I took
one abnormal site class. I'm the king of psychology. Now, we
end on that
I hope this guy's happy. I hope this guy's actually happy with
himself. Okay, you could have joined the Discord. You should
talk about Destiny. I have no idea who she's talking about here,
dude.
I have no clue.
Nope. Still not here. All right. >> I'm going to jump out
quickly.
>> Talk to you later. See you. Okay, guys. Who's the raid
going to? Who we raiding?
Who we raiding? Who we raiding? This Murk? I think I think it's
uh probably Okay. No, no, no, no, no. Nick Wick Lee doing chat
roulette. It looks like I don't think it's it's not monkey. It's
like chat roulette or omega. So omega. Omegle. Omega. Omegle.
That's where you're going, guys. Nick Wickley
doing Omegle right now. Coming at you in his Chinese crown.
There it is. We'll talk to you guys later. I'll be back tomorrow.
Okay. Have a good night. Bye-bye.